I was really moved by so many things I'm
happened tonight it was really Elizabeth
Banks hosted night two of the Democratic
National Convention and et was there
just minutes after the actress and
director stepped off the stage the crowd
went wild for this star-studded viral
video banks co-produced for Democratic
presidential nominee Hillary Clinton and
he's hearing that song and I love Rachel
Platten and she said yeah let's let's do
it let's do an acapella version there's
harmony in this and strength and many
many voices and that I just felt like
that message would be carried if we made
that kind of video out of the fight song
beatboxing in that video I think you
were I mean I do not have gravy but
definitely made me sound better that I
actually be Bucks on the day but I tried
is there a word to Donald Trump Michelle
Obama you know that was shade of the
highest water and you know she's she's
so gracious and regal and amazing and
Bill clinking a great speech tonight but
Michelle Obama just blew me away
you